welcome back everybody we are here with
Hannah wadding I'm giving up are you
ready
I love how competitive you are I'm as
well Hannah has starred in musicals like
Spamalot and into the woods on Broadway
and West End because she's fabulous so
in honor of Hannah's musical Roots it is
time to play a round of throw me a line
[Music]
all right we need a host so here to do
the honors please welcome a man who you
know from the hit shows Veep as well as
a man who who plays a host actually in
the upcoming final season of The
Marvelous Mrs maisel on Prime video red
Scott everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so great I know thank you for
hosting thank you for having me so you
played a host right I just thought you
could nail this this is I'm coming for
your job now okay great great do it I
give you control of the show yes the
control well thank you very much I can't
believe that you'll present
s
so here's how the show's going to work
I'm going to read a single line from a
popular song the first person to buzz in
and sing the song including the title
gets the point so so if I say for
example up above the world so high like
a diamond in this guy you hit the button
and you sing
tiny twinkle twinkle little
and the way we're gonna award it so if
if Hannah gets the point okay the right
side of the audience is going to win a
prize okay all right
you don't sound excited oh my God the
pressure they don't have faith in you
they have no friends
and if you win this side against
exactly
yeah I'm ready all right
ready yes you guys you're gonna do the
hoverboard oh yeah yeah it's the first
line okay so once upon a time I was
falling in love now I'm only fought Once
Upon a Time
now I'm only falling apart
[Applause]
can they have half a present for harmony
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm actually I'm gonna award myself a
point for that too because that is the
song that my high school girlfriend
broke up to me
thank you wait did she show you the
video or did she just play you the song
because this video is kind of amazing
she sat me down and said I don't know
how to say this so just listen to this
song are you
this guy gets it okay all right next one
here we go
my loneliness is killing me and I must
confess I still believe what really
Give Me A Sign baby oh my god wow
wow
[Applause]
like not even a little okay okay one to
one and a half all right
next one this one I love this song
because it's got some of the weirdest
lyrics ever but it starts with I'm on
the hunt I'm after you uh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
oh this is worth five okay so this is
come back time oh my God okay
someday somebody's gonna make you want
to turn around someday somebody's gonna
make you run baby are you gonna let them
all do not make you cry
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't even say the title I said hold
on
and that's lovely sound means that the
game is over and Kelly
thank you
in our games it doesn't matter because
no one goes home empty-handed so riddle
is a female founded luxury fragrance oil
and Skin Care brand that's vegan
non-toxic and cruelty free which is
awesome they offer roll on perfume spray
lotions neck to toe body oil and limited
edition candles they want their scents
to inspire you to be more confident so
you're all getting a 300 gift card to
riddles
not just a half
the final Seasons had left there is now
an Apple TV plus we'll talk with Reed
about his role on The Marvelous Mrs maze
when we get back dirt here
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]